new epicenter of the covet crisis
investors are calculating india's role
in the global economic recovery
and we're learning it's more crucial
than previously anticipated
and is netflix already past its peak as
the world is beginning to reopen from
covet 19 lockdowns fewer people are
signing up for the service and that's
worrying investors
we'll discuss what it means for the
future of the streaming service and
other work from home
stocks that were embraced early on in
the pandemic i'm tim stenovich and i'm
jennifer zabasanja and this is quick
take charge
let's get going
[Music]
well it was a verdict heard around the
world former minneapolis police officer
derek chovin was found
guilty of killing george floyd when he
knelt on floyd's neck for nine minutes
and
29 seconds a videotaped death that
ignited a summer of protest and marked
the beginning
of the greatest racial reckoning in the
u.s since the 60s and now
president biden is calling on congress
to honor george floyd's passing
honor george floyd by passing lasting
law enforcement reform
house democrats have passed legislation
that imposes restrictions on
federal authorities but in the senate
the bill doesn't have a clear path to a
to a filibuster-proof 60-vote majority
joining us now is senior staff attorney
at the
aclu some trevetti and bloomberg news's
white house reporter mario parker both
of them are in washington dc for us
uh so samia we wanted to start with you
first of all let's get your reaction to
three guilty verdicts uh yesterday what
did you think
well thanks for having me i think um
relief is probably the word that a lot
of people are feeling here uh
i think a lot of folks are also calling
it justice which i would stop
short of uh it's a it's a small measure
of accountability i hope it brings
healing to the family and the community
but
for true justice we need to make sure
that the george floyds of the world
never get killed in the first place so
they can go home to their families like
everybody else
so we have a long way to go hey mario to
somill's point
about true justice making sure that this
doesn't happen in the future
take us into what's happening in in
washington d.c
about changes that we could potentially
see
if democrats are able to pull this off
no absolutely we saw president biden
come out with remarks
yesterday evening and the bulk of those
remarks were
his using the bully pulpit to push
uh the george floyd policing act
um he was really throwing the weight of
the white house behind it
saying that this is the moment for uh
that type of legislation to pass
to get past some of the gridlock as well
um
you see excuse me you see some of the
the normal
you know chokeholds and strangleholds in
in dc right now in terms of legislation
but you also see some type of glimmers
some some glimmers of hope
in the form of bipartisanship tim scott
was out
a republican with a statement as well as
amy klobuchar
so there are some glimmers of hope that
something can be reached
so so what could be uh mario what what
could be like a federal
law though you know so because we do do
have some of these changes happening
throughout the country or at least being
proposed in different states and
as you mentioned in washington dc what
could the federal government do
in order to put restrictions in place to
hopefully
i i can't say never happen again because
we've already seen this happen
uh since last year but but to prevent
this from from continuing yeah what
we're seeing also of course is just uh
the limitations of the executive branch
uh joe biden over the past year as
candidate then candidate biden
has called for police reform of course
the george floyd
protests occurred during the backdrop of
the presidential election
he's come out since assuming office with
executive orders
but of course those only go so far the
only thing that could really have
lasting change and the administration is
admitting as much
is if some type of congressional
legislation is passed
again we've got a 50-50 deadlock in d.c
as you all mentioned at the top of the
the show
george floyd act uh passed in the house
it's kind of stalled in the senate the
senate has issues with the filibuster
etc
uh but uh the the white house is trying
as much as they can at least
from what we understand and from what
they're telling telling us
to uh really prod congress and the hill
to
to move forward with something and samil
you tweeted that this was just a verdict
and justice is yet to come and you also
reiterated that just now
um are the bills that you have seen out
there the george floyd justice and
policing act do they go far enough
and if not what more do you want to see
from legislators
yeah a lot more um i was really
disappointed by the reports that
uh this verdict is quote unquote easing
the pressure i mean talk about not
reading a room right millions of people
did not march
all summer last year to get one verdict
out of one courtroom in minnesota they
marched to get lasting systemic
eradication
of police brutality and systemic racism
so
um we are not nearly done the bills in
congress now are
are good we look forward to working with
the senate to get something
even better and namely um we need to
make sure that we are not
pumping money back in to the broken
systems of training and technology
that have failed us so far instead we
need to get that money back into
communities
and extract police from a lot of the
low-level interactions that get us into
these dangerous situations in the
first place yeah so
the the the guilty verdict on these
three charges is obviously a huge part
of this but sentencing is still
coming in the future we don't know what
the sentencing will be
uh but i'm wondering how you think the
judge is thinking about sentencing and
and also
how sentencing will send a message
yeah you know so i take a little
different view here um
sentencing will take a message we'll
send a message we know that the
prosecution has
asked for aggravating factors to be
tacked on
so that the ultimate sentence is
probably closer to
the maximums allowed under minnesota law
um
uh i hope frankly in eight weeks when
we're talking about sentencing
the national conversation has moved so
far forward
into prevention and reinvesting in
communities that it's a non-story but
i don't doubt that the prosecution will
try to send a message
to other uh police officers not just the
other ones in george floyd's own case
but
around the country and mario we want to
bring you back in here um
you mentioned senator tim scott and
there's a number of other lawmakers who
are also
trying to push for reform what is
happening though behind the scenes to
get more republicans on board because
tim scott is going to need
republicans in order to get this passed
it's a tough slog senator scott has been
working on this since last summer
he actually was able to get support from
then president trump but they couldn't
really rally the party around
the large-scale changes that
that advocates say are needed for
policing reform
so it's going to be a really tough slog
uh it's a politically
uh you know divisive issue it's a
politically fraught issue even within
the republican caucus
so it's going to be tough for him to
rally or get to really rally around
and get support uh to cross bipartisan
lines and get something across the the
finish line here
hey somal very briefly um
if we think a year from now what is the
the legacy
of of this verdict going to be
i think um it allowed us the breathing
room to have the larger conversations
that i'm talking about we can all
imagine what would have happened
if this system let down black and brown
communities yet again
um and so it's almost the absence
of a catastrophe that we can celebrate
here
and hopefully over the next year like i
said we'll be
well down the road to having a
conversation about how to make sure that
this never happens again
aclu's senior staff attorney so mel
trevetti and
bloomberg's mario parker a big thank you
to both of you for your time really
appreciate you joining us
on this well let's talk covid it's time
now for quick take by the numbers it's
where we give you the numbers that tell
the story this morning's number is 2
000. the world health organization said
that chronovirus cases are rising in all
regions except
europe with india driving a surge in
asia india reported a record of more
than 2 thousand deaths on wednesday
while cases rose by nearly 300 000
india's health system is being overrun
it's not just a humanitarian disaster
but it also poses real risks to the
global economy and the recovery
india has nearly 18 of the planet's
population and the fifth largest economy
it's not just the high risk of further
dangerous virus mutations in such an
uncontrolled outbreak
the country accounts for more than 12
percent of the world's labor force
that's according to world bank data
as bloomberg macro strategist mark
cudmore has written the disruption to
work and supply chains could be yet
another spur for global inflation
the rise in global cases has upset
financial markets solid earnings from
u.s companies have been overshadowed by
the threat of new lockdowns
sapping optimism that growth is set to
roar back from pandemic
induced recessions and for more on the
latest we're joined by the senior
scholar with the
hopkins center for health security dr
amesh adalja in pittsburgh
dr adalja thanks so much for being here
so the u.s
is set to meet president biden's latest
vaccine goal of administering
200 million coronavirus shots in his
first 100
days in office with more than 50 percent
of adults at least
partially vaccinated and biden is
expected to outline his plans
later today to ramp up vaccination
efforts
um what are you expecting to hear what
are you going to be looking out for
what i expect to hear is how we're going
to turn covet vaccination into something
that's more routine
something that's easily accessible
that's more like a flu vaccine in terms
of the
logistics to sign up for one than it has
been in the past
i also want to hear about how we're
going to get those vaccine hesitant
people to be persuaded that this is
something that they should do that this
is something that will improve their
individual lives because
increasingly we're becoming less supply
constrained and more demand constrained
if you look yesterday
uh less than two million doses were
given on
on tuesday so this is something we have
to worry about that are we kind of
hitting a peak
in terms of the people who want to get
vaccinated are all getting vaccinated
and we're left with a group that's
not willing to get vaccinated and that's
going to be an obstacle if we're going
to get
more control of these community cases
and have less disruption
of from the from the virus in our
business places in our in our schools
wherever it may be and i really think
that's going to be the challenge going
forward
you know dr adalja it seems to me that
one way to do this is is messaging and
messaging the clear benefits
of the vaccine it's something that
struck me yesterday with your appearance
on bloomberg tv and bloomberg radio
i i heard it throughout the day
yesterday the way that you talked about
how life changes after getting the
vaccine
i got to tell you it seems like you are
in the minority of
physicians out there right now talking
about
how much life can change just after
getting that single shot
who you can spend time with where you
can go wearing a mask outside versus not
wearing a mask outside
what do you think can what is the right
message to tell people who get the
vaccine
and why aren't we hearing more health
professionals say that
i hope that mine is the right message
because i've been somebody that is ahead
of the public health guidance in terms
of
what i think people can do safely once
they've been fully vaccinated and i tell
my friends i tell my patients
that they can go back to as much of
their original life as possible because
these vaccines are
highly effective not only preventing
symptomatic disease but also decreasing
spread you don't really have to worry
about you yourself being a spread
a spreader of this virus and i think
what you see is many public health
officials
being very cautious they kind of want to
take baby steps they don't want to give
away too much because they think things
might get out of control again
and that people that are not vaccinated
might take the wrong message
but i think if you're not telling people
what the vaccine is going to do to their
individual
life they're not going to want to get it
if you tell them every nothing changes
once you get the vaccine and you
advertise that fact
who's going to want to get a vaccine
because this is something that needs to
be seen as
something that's going to going to
better your individual life it's going
to allow you to pursue your
values and allow you to be able to do
things without the worry of coping 19.
it does seem like officials are being
overly cautious though i mean i think
back to what dr fauci said a couple
weeks ago that even after getting the
vaccine he's not going to eat inside at
a restaurant do you think that's the
right move i mean are you going to eat
inside a restaurant
you've already gotten the vaccine i've
i've been eating in restaurants even
before i got the vaccine because i think
it can be done safely if you take
calculated risks
but yes once i was fully vaccinated i
went back to as much of my
normal life as as i could i think that
we've gotta
use that as the kind of uh at the at the
pot at the end of the rainbow that
you're going to get to some place where
life looks normal because that's why
people would want to get the vaccine
they're doing it to get their lives back
and i
i don't know why they don't say more of
this i think that they've undersold the
vaccine and then they're surprised that
there's vaccine hesitancy
they've created this pause of the
johnson johnson vaccine which is going
to add to vaccine hesitancy
and if we don't talk to people about how
this vaccine
is a piece of technology that's going to
make their lives better just like an
iphone makes your life better it's a
piece of technology they're not going to
want to get it
they're and we're not going to get that
group of vaccine hesitant people to move
or to budge and that means we're still
going to have tens of thousands of cases
occurring every day
and that we're going to be worried about
new variants and all the rest of it so
we have to really tell people that this
is
this is something they should do for
their own life that this is something
that's going to
to to change what they can do and i
think that we want the guidance to be
proactive right now the cdc guidance is
lagging
people were already meeting with other
vaccinated people people were already
traveling
before the cdc guidance said okay yes
that's safe to do that makes that
guidance less relevant the cdc needs to
be ahead of it
talking about what people what people
will be doing
sooner talking about mass gatherings
talking about
vaccinated only sections in in sporting
and sporting
arenas all of that needs to be out there
so people can see this vaccine
as something they want to get like i
said the demand is
is the demand is going to start falling
away as we get into the general
population because it's not the high
risk individuals it's not the health
care workers who are
eager to sign up that we're dealing with
now so so it's going to be a challenge
and i think we have to speak honestly
and and not overly cautious
talk about what we don't know talk about
where the limitations are but
talk about what we do know and talk
about how to make calculated risks once
you're
vaccinated and we've been doing too much
abstinence only throughout this entire
pandemic
and we need to borrow from harm
reduction which we use in hiv and
sexually transmitted infections and with
injection drug use we need to take that
paradigm and it's been sorely missing
the entire pandemic and i think it's
created this breach between public
health and the general public
all right senior scholar with the
hopkins center for health security dr
amae shadal joe we always love having
you thanks so much for your time
uh and we should note the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health is
supported by
michael r bloomberg founder of bloomberg
lp and bloomberg
philanthropies now we don't want to bury
the lead on the rest of the morning's
top news so here are some stories we
don't want you to miss
columbus police shot and killed a
teenage girl who swung at two other
people
with a knife on tuesday according to
body cam footage from
the officer it happened minutes
reportedly before the george floyd
verdict
the decision to swiftly release the
video was a departure from protocol as
the force faces
immense scrutiny from the public
following a series of
recent high-profile police killings that
have led to clashes columbus mayor
andrew ginther mourned the loss of the
young victim
but defended the officer's use of deadly
force
and remember that rebel soccer league in
europe well it's fallen apart just days
after its launch the chairman of italy's
juventus club
says the project will no longer go ahead
the collapse was inevitable
after all six english teams involved
pulled out of the so-called super league
the idea as you may remember was blasted
by fans politicians and
soccer authorities and a ransomware
attack
may have stolen blueprints of apple's
latest prod
products during its announcement
yesterday one of apple's primary
suppliers quanta
was hit with the ransomware attacks from
a russian operator
the ransom was 50 million dollars quanta
acknowledged and attacked without
explaining if or how much of its data
was actually stolen
you can always learn more about these
stories and of course stay up to date on
the day's news at bloomberg.com
well coming up we are talking streaming
how did netflix miss its own subscriber
growth by millions
and should the company be concerned
investors certainly are we're back in
two minutes with the details this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
this is the difference
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in
new york well let's talk streaming to
netflix reeling
this morning from the brutal reality
that an end of the pandemic
is bad for business netflix revealed
user growth for the first quarter
and it missed its own forecast by
millions of subscribers
the streaming service added 3.98 million
subscribers in the first quarter
uh sounds like a lot but analysts
expected an average of 6.29 million
and its own forecast also was 6 million
netflix says the current quarter will be
more challenging which could be
the case for other work from home
businesses we've been
relying on during the pandemic on the
phone to discuss is bloomberg
intelligence senior media analyst
gita ragnagathen who has been unpacking
netflix's earnings
and wrote it's important not to confuse
near-term noise in user gains
with netflix's longer-term thesis which
we believe remains stronger
than ever gita thanks so much for taking
the time
explain what you mean here because it
really sounds similar to the point that
netflix executives were making last
night
in that earnings live stream it's
something they've talked about for years
right there can be noise with these
subscriber figures but
in the long run netflix is going to win
out
yeah um absolutely tim and uh saying
good morning tim and jennifer and thank
you so much for having me so this was
really the core i mean we've been
hearing about
you know this blowout in 2020 what's
going to happen in 2021
but this was really the quarter when
that pull forward of demand
hit hard uh but i think you know again
it
it's
as you just mentioned i think it's
really important to kind of distinguish
between
you know the short-term transitory
issues that we're going to see with
the subscriber outlook and the long-term
growth potential
um and you typically look at netflix in
any given year
before the pandemic hit and they've
added about 28 to 30 million subscribers
on average
of course last year was you know a
one-off they added about 40 million
but then you look at the long-term
growth potentially looked at the
long-term growth
trajectory and i think it remains pretty
much intact of course we are going to
have to deal with another
you know probably three to six months of
you know a little bit of ups and downs
and a little bit of noise when it comes
to the subscriber edition
the gita i mean there are still a number
of other streaming platforms out there
right so
what what does netflix need to do to
continue to keep customers
on the platform what is that long-term
strategy that you're talking about
oh absolutely so competition is is not
something that's new to netflix
what they really have to do is come out
with more and more original content and
they have recognized this i mean
originals and exclusivity is what is
going to
you know win the streaming wars for
netflix they know this
they have gone hard after you know
original content
and not just buying originals from other
studios but kind of
making their own originals think of
shows like stranger things think of
shows like you know the witcher or
bridgeton these are all shows that they
own they own the ip and they can you
know
they have plenty of flexibility they can
do whatever they want to do with the
show
and they know that and and um you know
they were spending about 15 billion
dollars uh
in terms of programming costs before the
pandemic hit but this year again
that's ramping up pretty significantly
they did commit to spending about 17
billion
or so and i think going out the next few
years we're going to see them spend
easily about
20 billion on content just to kind of
you know make
those high-profile shows make those
high-profile movies
and all your new subscribers that is a
lot of money to spend on content gita
i'm wondering how the coronavirus
pandemic has derailed
production worldwide because the thing
about netflix is it's so
easy to sign up for but it's just as
easy to quit if you don't have anything
to watch
yes and i mean that is kind of the big
uh the question mark for all of these
streaming services right i mean
yes easy to sign up but also easy to
kind of churn out of it
it is obviously a huge concern but i
think if you just kind of compare
netflix uh both in terms of quality and
quantity of content i think they have
established themselves as the go-to
service
and then you kind of look at them and
their price points versus their
competitors
um yes they're pricey but i think again
the value proposition is compelling
so again just to go back to your point
on on originals and on productions
covet 19 has obviously derailed
productions there was a there was you
know
these huge shutdowns and that's kind of
taken a toll on this first
half content slate which is why which is
partly responsible for
uh you know both the uh lower
subscribers and one in one queue as well
as the weak guidance for 2q
but i think ironically what's going to
happen is i think netflix is also going
to kind of be coming
become this reopening play because as
those covet productions ease you're
going to see
so much more content kind of come on
board uh
in the second half uh you know as we
have those reopenings and
i think that is really going to drive a
huge increase in subscriber gain so they
already talked about a lot of their big
heavy hitting titles coming on online
you know you have the witcher you have
kobrakai you have
money heist these are all titles that
attract a lot of subscribers i think
they should be in pretty good shape
in the latter part of the year oh man
even more content on netflix just what
we need right
uh bloomberg intelligence senior media
analyst gita ragnaronthen
thank you so much for your time and for
your insight this morning up next
why more people are getting into clean
energy investments and how that changes
the timeline for earth shifts
from fossil fuels to renewables we'll be
back in two minutes this is quick take
[Music]
charge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey welcome back to take charge i'm
jennifer zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec
in
new york well joe biden has touted the
potential for the solar and wind
industries to create the types of jobs
that the u.s economy has been losing for
decades
and investors see there are good
opportunities in sustainable innovations
bank of america says clean energy
investments grew 47
from 2019 to 2020 and continues to grow
with some 50 percent of advisors putting
money toward
five or more sustainable assets for
clients analysts are also bullish with
ubs predicting that
electric vehicles will be 100 of the
automobile market by the year 2040.
here to discuss is jackie vanderbrugg
bank of america's head of sustainable
and impact investing for its chief
investment office
who's buying into green stocks and which
industries are getting the most play
jackie what are you seeing
so we do see this as a broad spectrum
tim
um like you say there's a lot of
tailwinds
but historically it's helpful to say
sustainable investors initially were
looking at either getting
out of certain industries avoiding or
just those specific uh pure play
clean energy stocks and now we see a
much broader
spectrum of opportunities they really do
run the gamut
from green bonds as you noted or
uh investments in companies that are
improving their environmental footprint
green munis investments in cities and
municipalities that have that
focus around infrastructure
on the equity side companies that are
outperforming their peers
from an environmental standpoint but
also those that are
improvers right those that are seeking
to make the investments that are going
to allow them to lead
and have opportunities for new revenue
streams
in the future and then on the private
side
a lot of work again in renewables as you
said but also
venture in carbon capture capture and
storage
so i think it's important to get the
fact that this is a
full spectrum across all asset classes
and across uh the risk spectrum as well
jackie how how crucial is it to uh
investing in in
renewables at this point in time
well we are seeing this energy
transition as
as you noted and the opportunity
that investors have i think they've seen
in a way that we maybe all knew
initially
um but we felt through the covent crisis
so we saw
kovit as this unexpected accelerant
where
individuals and institutions now
saw the vulnerability that we all have
whether it's that pandemics don't
stop at borders whether it's that
extreme weather is
increasing and affecting all of us we're
we have this
collective knowledge the other side is
that we are clearly seeing that
sustainable investments
broadly are out uh are not
underperforming which was the myth i
will say the historically
sustainable investments um including
these investments in renewables
were seen as riskier or a way to
ethically lose money and what we've done
is we've really disproved that
so we we've seen over the past years
that
sustainable investments are performing
um at a risk-adjusted basis better than
their peers in their asset classes
and that really has made investors uh
wake up and be very excited jackie i
want to talk a little bit about
incentives specifically tax incentives
because there are a lot of reasons to
invest in sustainables but the tax
benefits are are really substantial
i'm i'm wondering if you can talk a
little bit about how
those tax benefits have played a role if
any
in the recent pledges that number in the
trillions of dollars
from some of the biggest banks in the
industry
so you are seeing a lot of pledges both
from
uh banks but also you know from from
countries right
you're seeing the the net zero pledges
pile up tim
and i think it is uh an understanding
that
we are in one of the largest transitions
um of our lifetimes and the
existential nature of this is important
but
the technology and the policy tailwinds
are
essential right but the knowledge of
this was there before
but as the regulators are looking for
more disclosure from a climate risk
perspective
and the policy makers are understanding
that tax incentives are
essential for getting various industries
moving
at the scale in which we need and the
pace which we need
we're actually getting that flywheel
moving so jackie where do you where do
you see this going in the next
year or so so i think we're going to see
a couple of different things we're going
to see more
policy and ideally more collective
or consistent policy around the world
clearly
europeans were ahead of us um the blind
administration
is moving forward and you're seeing
action and signaling
from you know all different departments
um
and also legislative action as well as
policy actions so a lot of movement
and and tailwind there i also think
you're seeing
corporates uh be much more transparent
about this this age of radical
transparency and specifically
stakeholder capitalism this idea that
companies that are delivering for their
employees that are delivering
for their customers and for the
communities in which they operate
those are the firms that over the long
term are going to deliver for their
shareholders
and so companies are disclosing to
things like the stakeholder capitalism
metrics
like the task force on climate related
risk disclosures so all of those
different pieces
will enable investors to more
holistically
evaluate the opportunities in this space
all right we're going to leave it there
jackie vanderbrog
bank of america's head of sustainable
and impact investing
for its chief investment office thanks
so much for your time and for your
insight this morning
coming up we're talking to obama's
former faith advisor about how he's
helping business leaders
engage with the cultural conversation
around race and
meaningful conversations around race
authentically we'll be back in two
minutes
this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim steinovich and i'm jennifer
zabasanja in new york
so within minutes of the reading of the
jury's guilty verdict
in the derek chovin murder trial
responses flooded in
many of them welcoming the news and many
more calling for even more change so
former president obama wrote on twitter
today a jury did the right thing
but true justice requires much more
nba player lebron james tweeted one word
accountability canadian prime minister
justin trudeau said on twitter in part
make no mistake systemic racism and
anti-black racism
still exist and they exist in canada too
our next guest
shared his reaction on twitter too
writing in part so much more work
to do but so grateful for this moment of
justice so joshua dubois is the ceo of
gage.ai
which advises executives at companies
including pinterest snapchat
and sephora on how to talk about race
and cancel proof
their campaigns and dei initiatives he
was also
the former faith advisor to president
obama joshua is joining us now
from maryland joshua thank you so much
for being here so first of all
we want to get your reaction to the
three guilty verdicts yesterday how did
it feel watching
for you it was a sigh of relief that
i had at that moment um it was a moment
of accountability and another step
towards justice this of course is not
perfect justice because
george floyd is not with us but we've
been on a long journey as a country and
this is another step
um towards greater equality and justice
joshua you you advise companies as jen
mentioned
including printer snap and and more i
want to talk a little bit about the
conversations that should be happening
inside office buildings right now over
zoom
as people remain virtually what is the
what is the the
the right way to talk about this uh
moving forward
yeah it's a great question you know the
first thing is to actually not talk it's
to listen right to listen to employees
and other internal stakeholders
listen to outside experts and and hear
from them about what
how they're processing this what they're
going through and what they think you
should do the second thing is to
really communicate solidarity that
you're standing with
impacted communities the third thing is
to do what you do best right you don't
necessarily have to get out of your lane
for example
one of our subscribers sephora is a
retailer and so they focus on the
problem
of racial bias in retail settings
another subscriber procter gamble
is one of the biggest advertisers in the
world and so they think about how they
can have
a more diverse and inclusive advertising
approach and how their um
the messages and the images that they
are communicating in their advertising
so focus on that
that you do best and think about how you
can have an impact there and joshua you
mentioned a few of the companies that
you're working with
um and that you worked with last summer
um has your work sort of changed
since we saw the killing of george floyd
last year i mean how has it evolved in
the past year
um and how do you expect it to evolve
especially now that we have these guilty
verdicts
sure well it's certainly grown and
increases we get a lot of incoming
requests so gauge.ai is a software
platform that
connects decision makers in brands with
leaders in culture
every day these are the types of leaders
in culture that used to just weigh in
after the fact we're bringing them
into the process confidentially early on
to weigh in on ad campaigns and
you know and messaging strategic
questions and more we're basically
closing the gap between cultural leaders
and decision makers and major brands and
so one of the things that we're seeing
is a lot of folks are saying
you know we have a strategic plan around
our products around our employees and
our hr strategy but we don't have plans
around
this changing culture and so we're
helping them develop those plans
and implement these new tools josh well
you heard jen read from
former president obama's tweet that he
sent in in the wake of this uh decision
from the jury
are you still in touch with with the
president do you still advise him
so yeah we are honored to stay close to
the both the former president and the
obama
foundation and support wherever we can
yeah have you talked to him about this
not about this subject no yeah i'm
wondering what you would
uh you know give me an idea of what you
have been been speaking with him about
and
and give us an idea of what he's been
thinking about since he has left office
and we've seen the conversation about
race change so much
well you know what i've seen the former
president and the former first lady
focus on is long-term systemic change so
for example with their my brother's
keeper initiative
thinking about how they can pour into
men and boys of color in the long run
setting up mentoring programs and
and other initiatives to really
strengthen those communities or the
first lady's efforts with women and
girls you know this is a
again a long journey we've been on as a
country we've
you know from slavery to jim crow to the
civil rights era and now we've had
basically
350 years of really tough stuff in just
50 or 60 years where we're just
beginning
um to figure some of these pieces out
and so what i've always appreciated
about the former president and and first
lady is that they're focused on the long
run and that's where their interventions
have been
and joshua i mean we're still seeing
corporations that are
are sometimes making these mistakes
right and making these embarrassing gaps
as as you've noted
uh what are three things that you would
advise them
uh if you were talking to them today
well first thing is
assess the tools that they're using to
evaluate you know their messaging
and and their ad campaigns and making
sure that those tools are inclusive
the second thing is listen to their
diverse employees right they're folks
that are
within these organizations that already
know sort of the best approach to these
issues and make sure those people
are empowered and the third is i
mentioned it before but do what you do
well you can stay in your lane and have
a massive impact whether that
is as a retailer as an advertiser
whatever the case may be in in real
estate you can
bring greater equity and equality in the
space that you're in
but focus on how you can have that
impact in your space hey joshua i wonder
how you think about progress in the
context of your own business because if
i think about gage.ai
it would be an ultimate sign of success
right if your company no longer
really needs to exist because those gaps
between the way that the boardroom is
thinking
and the the way that uh the conversation
is happening outside of the company
like that would no longer exist right
well the interesting thing is that you
know there's always
going to be brilliant leaders in culture
who who want to make sure that they are
shaping decisions within these board
rooms and so
we are basically a platform that serves
as that connecting point
it's interesting it's actually diverse
leaders in these organizations that are
reaching out to us most saying we need
better tools
to bring to others in our organization
so i think we will be able to grow
as these companies grow more sensitive
and nuance to these issues
who else are you working with joshua i
mean we mentioned a few of the companies
but uh
where else will you be uh lending your
efforts
yeah so you know as we talked about
sephora and racial bias and retail and
procter and gamble and the work that
they're doing in advertisement
we love working for example with
snapchat as they develop
more inclusive ar tools and we're
helping them shape those tools in
partnership with
uh with diverse leaders we're working
with pinterest with the cw network
a cable network thinking about how they
are
portraying diverse communities on screen
and so the work is really growing right
now and we're honored to advise these
leaders and most importantly connect
them using software
with stakeholders and communities joshua
dubois ceo of gage.ai joshua thanks so
much for taking the time
really appreciate you joining us on
quick take today well coming up
we're looking at how the pandemic
reinvented the at-home fitness
industry also what's going to happen to
peloton when in-person studios and
boutique fitness classes start
all up again we're back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well the at-home
smart fitness boom flourish during the
pandemic will boutique studios shudder
so what happens when the pandemic passes
quick take chief correspondent jason
kelly explores peloton's rise
and more in his latest episode of
business of sport out tomorrow
here's a sneak peek
we saw the sail spike you know almost
right away
not just that people were finding out
about peloton and interested in
the bike or the tread but that they had
no choice
peloton went from a kickstarter project
to a company worth more than
30 billion dollars in just a few years
but as the world starts to slowly return
to normal what happens next for at home
fitness
there's an interesting survey that we
saw that 59 percent of americans
said they're not going back to the gym
after covet if you don't think that
represents a big opportunity for peloton
to continue
selling bikes and treads so you're crazy
what's up peloton
yes welcome to my house i am coming to
you live from my parents home
when those classes live from home came
out it was
a super special moment for for
internally
at the folks at peloton we really wanted
to be there for them with not just
content because you could have taken a
class from
last year but something authentic took
place when we didn't
live from home because it's hey i'm here
peloton stock which opened in 2019
to a tepid response grew into one of the
best performing stocks in the world
even amid a massive bull market and
let's be honest the peloton
it's expensive yes you can finance it
but this is a bike that costs on average
about twenty five hundred dollars just
to get it then you've got a monthly fee
on top of that every other person you
talk to will say what happens to pelton
after cover
people think that it's dark dark clouds
on the horizon for peloton
that pessimism and disbelief in us fuels
our you know fuels our fire and there's
still
so many naysayers that we're excited to
prove wrong
well jason kelly is here with us now
jason thanks so much for
joining us look you literally wrote the
book on connected fitness right
sweat equity it came out a few years ago
you use a peloton as you talk about in
this
and looking back over the last year i
mean it kind of seems inevitable that
peloton would have this moment
but many dismiss this company from its
earliest days
as something that wouldn't actually
catch on take us through what you've
learned
well absolutely tim i mean i was one of
those people when i wrote that book back
in 2016
peloton was really just coming on the
scene in many ways i knew about it
i knew that people were liking it to
some extent but it wasn't catching on
really with investors
and i like many others thought you know
what that's not where fitness is going
we're in an era where people want to be
with other people in these cool boutique
studios and that was really
my focus that was true for a time but
even
before the pandemic peloton caught onto
something it figured out how to marry
technology
and community and obviously as we just
heard
the pandemic it just went gangbusters
and jason i mean john
seems so confident that uh you know
peloton is going to continue
uh its popularity with consumers i mean
where does that come from
i think it comes from the the depth and
the devotion of the community community
so far i mean
these are people who feel very connected
pun intended
to this brand there are you know
facebook groups that have built up
around this
massive social media presence they've
also expanded pretty dramatically
away from the bike you know into the
treadmill into
you know all sorts of other modalities
as they say the
app is very very popular you know given
you can do pilates and yoga
and boot camp type workouts so they see
as as you heard john say just a huge
amount of upside going forward
it seems like jason a real big part of
ingredient in the secret sauce
is the celebrity instructors these
instructors that they have take us into
who they are
how they're able to make the transition
during the pandemic to go from studio
in home and how they're compensated
because
they're making some serious money they
are making some serious money and and
that's because they
are as you say they're celebrities in
many ways
and i do think you know one of the
brilliant things that peloton was able
to do and john talks about this in depth
in the piece
is they set these folks up at home and
by they
the instructors themselves had to set
themselves up and i mean you guys all
remember we couldn't leave our houses we
certainly couldn't have
anyone into our house and so you had
these technicians who were you know on
facetime being like all right put the
camera here put the camera there
and there they were doing classes from
home and
the reason that they are so beloved in
many ways is there is a real intimacy
uh that they create and that only was
heightened i think during the pandemic
and jason i'll say it because i have
used a valentine
before and i love these instructors so
much and really like you mentioned i
mean there's a connection
that they make with the audience there's
the hashtags that you mentioned
um does that mean going forward i mean
is there anybody that can compete with
peloton at this point i mean you
mentioned all of the other
offerings that they have they have bar
they have pilates they have outdoor
running i mean can anyone
compete with where peloton has gone at
this point well they're certainly trying
to and you know one of the interesting
newer but actually not so new entrants
in all of this but you know gaining
a little bit of attention is beachbody
you probably remember them from
insanity and p90x they are going public
via spac
they have an investment from kevin mayer
who ran a big chunk of disney and then
went on to run tick-tock thomas stags
who also worked at disney
their spac is what's taking a beachbody
public and interestingly
mixed fitness i believe tim spoke with
the president of mix herbie countless
not too long ago
mix is part of that new beachbody so
they've got a lot of competition coming
and some of the competition is candidly
going to be
people going back to the boutique
studios well so to so to that point
jason
and i love the way that your piece
starts out because it like really took
me back on memory lane thinking about
workout videos like straight up vhs
videos at home fitness
it's nothing new right this didn't start
during the pandemic
but the road to peloton is is littered
with the carcasses of companies that
really were had a hot moment but aren't
really doing well
anymore and you speak to some of these
people um how do you prevent or how does
john foley prevent
peloton from being a pandemic fad i
think you
they have to continually innovate they
have to continually come up with
the content i mean this is ultimately a
content company in
in many ways yes it's a technology
company yes it's a fitness company
but the content is what wins the day
going back to what we were talking about
with the instructors so
it's got to be fresh it's got to be
engaging it's got to be engaging in a
way
that you feel like not only you have a
connection with the instructors
but this broader community around them
and
that is going to be critical sort of
keeping
that group together going forward it'll
be so interesting to watch and
we will be watching it jason we know you
will be too quick take chief
correspondent jason kelly
thanks so much for your time and for
your reporting of course and you can
check out the next episode of business
of sports tomorrow morning on quick
takes youtube page
up next the white house is doubling down
on obama-era emission standards we'll be
back in two minutes this is quick take
charge
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenoveck and i'm jennifer zabasanja
in new york let's look at some
developing stories we are tracking this
morning
white house officials have told
supporters they will pledge
to reduce u.s greenhouse gas emissions
by at least
half by the end of the decade that's an
almost doubling
of the nation's earlier commitment the
goals being discussed
ahead of this week's international
climate summit
prescription eyewear seller warby parker
is considering an ipo
possibly this year bloomberg has learned
the company is in talks
with advisors warby parker raised 120
million in its most recent funding round
in 2020 that gave it a valuation of 3
billion
and you can learn more about these
stories and stay up to date on the day's
news
at bloomberg.com you have warby parkers
right jen i do i have them on right now
and i was just
yeah i was just talking to them actually
yesterday it has been i mean look it's
been a long time coming for this company
it's been a venture back company for for
years and years they went with that
tom's model the one for one we recently
had jordan holman on the show who wrote
an article about toms how they're moving
away from that one-to-one model
i really look forward to seeing the s1
the prospectus from warby parker and and
seeing how they're thinking about
charitable giving moving forward and
also whether they've moved into
other parts of the business when it
comes to eyewear like contact lenses for
example yeah
and they're totally expensive i mean
they're opening more brick and mortar
stores and so it's just going to be
really interesting to see
where this company continues to go and
we of course will continue to bring the
latest when we get it well that's going
to do it for quick take this hour but
there is much more quick take coming up
in just a minute i'm tim steinovich and
i'm jennifer zabasaja you can check out
the latest stories at bloomberg.com or
at quicktake on social media
thanks for watching
hmm
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to bloomberg
quick take where we bring you today's
top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
coming up
today world leaders and activists are
calling derek chovin's guilty verdict
a turning point in the fight for justice
under minnesota law
he he faces up to four decades in prison
but this
is only one case and while the verdict
could change how police use excessive
force
it also might relieve pressure from
congress to act on police reform we'll
talk with the aclu
senior staff attorney of its criminal
law reform project and
former president obama's spiritual
advisor then all eyes are on india which
is turning into the new epicenter of the
covid crisis
investors are calculating india's role
in the global economic recovery
and we're learning it's more crucial
than previously anticipated and
is netflix already past its peak as the
world is beginning to reopen from covet
19 lockdowns
fewer people are signing up for the
service and that's worrying investors
we'll discuss what it means for the
future of the streaming service and
other work from home stocks that were
embraced early on in the pandemic
i'm tim stenovich and i'm jennifer
zabasanja and this is quick take charge
let's get going
well it was a verdict heard around the
world former minneapolis police officer
derek chovin was found
guilty of killing george floyd when he
knelt on floyd's neck for nine minutes
and 29 seconds a videotaped
death that ignited a summer of protest
and marked the beginning
of the greatest racial reckoning in the
us since the 60s and now
president biden is calling on congress
to honor george floyd's passing
honor george floyd by passing lasting
law enforcement reform
house democrats have passed legislation
that imposes restrictions on
federal authorities but in the senate
the bill doesn't have a clear path to a
to a filibuster-proof 60-vote majority
joining us now is senior staff attorney
at the aclu
some trevetti and bloomberg news's white
house reporter mario parker both of them
are in washington dc for us
uh so samia we wanted to start with you
first of all let's get your reaction to
three guilty verdicts uh yesterday what
did you think
well thanks for having me i think um
relief is probably the word that a lot
of people are feeling here
i think a lot of folks are also calling
it justice which i would stop short
of uh it's a it's a small measure of
accountability i hope it brings healing
to the family and the community but
for true justice we need to make sure
that the george floyds of the world
never get killed in the first place so
they can go home to their families like
everybody else
so we have a long way to go hey mario to
somil's point
about true justice making sure that this
doesn't happen in the future
take us into what's happening in in
washington d.c
about changes that we could potentially
see
if democrats are able to pull this off
no absolutely we saw president biden
come out with remarks
yesterday evening and the bulk of those
remarks were
his using the bully pulpit to push
uh the george floyd policing act
um he was really throwing the weight of
the white house behind it
saying that this is the moment for that
type of legislation to pass
to get past some of the gridlock as well
you see excuse me you see some of the
the normal
you know chokeholds and strangleholds in
in dc right now in terms of legislation
but you also see some type of glimmers
some some glimmer
like so many of you all right attorney
general merrick garland is addressing
the public
following that chauvin verdict yesterday
let's listen in
successful i know that nothing can fill
the void
that the loved ones of george floyd have
felt since his death
my heart goes out to them and to all
those
who have experienced similar loss
i know such wounds have deep roots
and that too many communities have
experienced those wounds
firsthand yesterday's verdict in the
state criminal trial does not address
potentially systemic policing issues in
minneapolis
today i am announcing that the justice
department has opened a civil
investigation
to determine whether the minneapolis
police department engages in a pattern
or practice
of unconstitutional or unlawful
policing this effort will be staffed by
experienced attorneys and other
personnel from the justice department's
civil rights division
and the u.s attorney's office for the
district of minnesota
the new civil investigation is separate
from
and independent of the federal criminal
investigation
into the death of george floyd that the
justice department has previously
announced
congress gave the department the
authority to conduct civil
practice pattern or practice
investigations
which looked beyond individual incidents
to assess
systemic failures those investigations
allow the department to determine
whether a police department
has a pattern or practice of
unconstitutional
or unlawful policing the investigation
i am announcing today will assess
whether the minneapolis police
department
engages in a pattern or practice of
using excessive force
including during protests the
investigation will also assess whether
the mpd engages in discriminatory
conduct
and whether its treatment of those with
behavioral health disabilities
is unlawful it will include a
comprehensive review
of the minneapolis police department's
policies
training supervision and use of force
investigations
it will assess the effectiveness of the
mpd's current
systems of accountability and whether
other mechanisms are needed
to ensure constitutional and lawful
policing
broad participation in this
investigation
from the community and from law
enforcement will be vital to its success
the justice department has already begun
to reach out to community groups and
members of the public to learn about
their experiences with the mpd
we also seek to hear from the
department's officers
about the training and support they
receive
because their perspective is essential
all these voices will help provide
investigators the
information they need to conduct a
comprehensive assessment
all these voices will be critical to the
reform efforts that will follow
if the investigation determines the
existence of constitutional
or statutory violations
if the justice department concludes that
there is reasonable cause to believe
there is a pattern or practice
of unconstitutional or unlawful policing
we will issue a public report of our
conclusions
the justice department also has the
authority to bring a civil lawsuit
asking a federal court to provide
injunctive relief that orders the mpd
to change its policies and practices to
avoid
further violations usually when the
justice department finds unlawful
practices or patterns of practices the
local police department
enters into a settlement agreement or a
consent decree
to ensure that prompt and effective
action is taken
to align policing practices with the law
most of our nation's law enforcement
officers do their difficult jobs
honorably and lawfully
i strongly believe that good officers do
not want to work in systems
that allow bad practices good officers
welcome accountability because
accountability
is an essential part of building trust
with the community
and public safety requires public trust
i have been involved in the legal system
in one way or another
for most of my adult life i know
that justice is sometimes slow sometimes
elusive
and sometimes never comes the department
of justice will be
unwavering in its pursuit of equal
justice
under law
the challenges we face are deeply woven
into our history
they did not arise today or last year
building trust between community and law
enforcement will take time
and effort by all of us
but we undertake this task with
determination
and urgency knowing that change
cannot wait thank you
all right you've been listening to
attorney general merrick garland
announcing a new doj
civil investigation into the minneapolis
pd
about and he says it's in looking into
whether the minneapolis police
department has a pattern or practice of
unlawful policing he said the doj will
also look into the mpd's use
of excessive force including during
protests they'll look into
discriminatory conduct at the mpd
and also investigate the training around
the use of force merrick garland
speaking there
so we're going to take you back to
regularly scheduled programming
more quick take the tip of the hour
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in
new york well let's talk streaming to
netflix reeling
this morning from the brutal reality
that an end of the pandemic
is bad for business netflix revealed
user growth for the first quarter and it
missed its own forecast by millions of
subscribers
the streaming service added a 3.98
million subscribers in the first quarter
uh sounds like a lot but analysts
expected an average of 6.29 million
and its own forecast also was six
million netflix says the current quarter
will be more challenging which could be
the case for other work from home
businesses
we've been relying on during the
pandemic on the phone to discuss is
bloomberg intelligence senior media
analyst
gita ragnagathen who has been unpacking
netflix's earnings
and wrote quote it's important not to
confuse near-term noise in user gains
with netflix's longer-term thesis which
we believe remains stronger than ever
gita thanks so much for taking the time
uh explain what you mean here because it
really sounds similar
to the point that netflix executives
were making last night
in that earnings live stream it's
something they've talked about for years
right there can be noise with these
subscriber figures but
in the long run netflix is going to win
out
yeah um absolutely tim and uh saying
good morning tim and jennifer and thank
you so much for having me so this was
really the core i mean we've been
hearing about
you know this blowout in 2020 what's
going to happen in 2021
but this was really the quarter when
that pull forward of demand
hit hard uh but i think you know again
it's
as you just mentioned i think it's
really important to kind of distinguish
between
you know the short-term transitory
issues that we're going to see with
the subscriber outlook and the long-term
growth potential
and you typically look at netflix in any
given year
before the pandemic hit and they've
added about 28 to 30 million subscribers
on average
of course last year was you know a
one-off they added about 40 million
but then you look at the long-term
growth potentially looked at the
long-term growth
trajectory and i think it remains pretty
much intact of course we are going to
have to deal with another
you know probably three to six months of
you know a little bit of ups and downs
and a little bit of noise when it comes
to the subscriber edition
but gita i mean there are still a number
of other streaming platforms out there
right so
what what does netflix need to do to
continue to keep
customers on the platform what is that
long-term strategy that you're talking
about
oh absolutely so competition is is not
something that's new to netflix
what they really have to do is come out
with more and more
original content and they have
recognized this i mean originals and
exclusivity is what is going to
you know win the streaming wars for
netflix they know this
they have gone hard after you know
original content
and not just buying originals from other
studios but kind of
making their own originals think of
shows like stranger things think of
shows like you know the witcher or
bridgeton these are all shows that they
own they own the ip and they can you
know
they have plenty of flexibility they can
do whatever they want to do with the
show
and they know that and and um you know
they were spending about 15 billion
dollars uh
in terms of programming costs before the
pandemic hit but this year again that's
ramping up
pretty significantly they did commit to
spending about 17 billion
or so and i think going out the next few
years we're going to see them spend
easily about 20 billion on content just
to kind of
you know make those high-profile shows
make those high-profile movies
and all your new subscribers that is a
lot
of money to spend on content gita i'm
wondering
how the coronavirus pandemic has
derailed production
worldwide because the thing about
netflix is it's so easy to sign up for
but it's just as easy to quit
if you don't have anything to watch yes
and i mean that is kind of the big uh
the question mark for all of these
streaming services right i mean
yes easy to sign up but also easy to
kind of churn out of it
it is obviously a huge concern but i
think if you just kind of compare
netflix
uh both in terms of quality and quantity
of content i think they have established
themselves as the go-to service
and then you kind of look at them and
their price points versus their
competitors
um yes they're pricey but i think again
the value proposition is compelling
so again just to go back to your point
on on originals and on productions
kobit 19 has obviously derailed
productions there was a there was you
know these huge shutdowns and that's
kind of taken a toll on this first
half content slate which is why which is
partly responsible for
uh you know both the uh lower
subscribers and one in one queue as well
as the weak guidance for 2q
but i think ironically what's going to
happen is i think netflix is also going
to kind of be coming
become this reopening play because as
those covet productions ease you're
going to see
so much more content kind of come on
board
in the second half uh you know as we
have those reopenings and
i think that is really going to drive a
huge increase in subscriber gain so they
already talked about
a lot of their big heavy hitting titles
coming on online you know you have the
witcher you have kobrakai you have
money heist these are all titles that
attract a lot of subscribers i think
they should be in pretty good shape
in the latter part of the year oh man
even more content on netflix just what
we need right
uh bloomberg intelligence senior media
analyst gita ragnaronthen
thank you so much for your time and for
your insight this morning up next
why more people are getting into clean
energy investments and how that changes
the timeline for earth's shifts
from fossil fuels to renewables we'll be
back in two minutes this is quick take
charge
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the difference
hey welcome back to take charge i'm
jennifer zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec
in
new york well joe biden has touted the
potential for the solar and wind
industries to create the types of jobs
that the u.s economy has been losing for
decades
and investors see there are good
opportunities in sustainable innovations
bank of america says clean energy
investments grew 47
from 2019 to 2020 and continues to grow
with some 50 percent of advisors putting
money toward
five or more sustainable assets for
clients analysts are also bullish with
ubs
predicting that electric vehicles will
be 100 of the automobile market by the
year 2040.
here to discuss is jackie vanderbrugg
bank of america's head of sustainable
and impact investing for its chief
investment office
who's buying into green stocks and which
industries are getting the most play
jackie what are you seeing
so we do see this as a broad spectrum
tim like you say there's a lot of
tailwinds but historically it's helpful
to say
sustainable investors initially were
looking at either
getting out of certain industries
avoiding
or just those specific uh pure play
clean energy stocks and now we see a
much broader
spectrum of opportunities they they
really do run the gamut from
green bonds as you noted or investments
in companies that are
improving their environmental footprint
green munis
investments in cities and municipalities
that have that
focus around infrastructure
on the equity side companies that are
outperforming their peers
from an environmental standpoint but
also those that are improvers right
those that
are seeking to make the investments that
are going to allow them to lead
and have opportunities for new revenue
streams in the future
and then on the private side a lot of
work
again in renewables as you said but also
venture
in carbon capture capture and storage so
i think it's important to get the fact
that this is a full
spectrum across all asset classes and
across
uh the risk spectrum as well jackie how
how crucial is it to uh investing in in
uh renewables at this point in time
well we are seeing this energy
transition
as as you noted and the opportunity that
investors have i think they they've seen
in a way that we maybe all
knew initially um but we felt
through the covet crisis so we saw kovit
as this
unexpected accelerant where individuals
and institutions now saw the
vulnerability that we all have
whether it's that pandemics don't stop
at
borders whether it's that extreme
weather is
increasing and affecting all of us we're
we have this
collective knowledge the other side is
that we are clearly
seeing that sustainable investments
broadly are out
uh are not underperforming which was the
myth i will say
the historically sustainable investments
um including these investments in
renewables
were seen as riskier or a way to
ethically lose money and what we've done
is we've really disproved that
so we we've seen over the past years
that
sustainable investments are performing
um at a risk-adjusted basis better than
their peers
in their asset classes and that really
has made investors
uh wake up and be very excited jackie i
want to talk a little bit
about incentives specifically tax
incentives because there are a lot of
reasons to
invest in sustainables but the tax
benefits are are really substantial
i'm wondering if you can talk a little
bit about how
those tax benefits have played a role if
any
in the recent pledges that number in the
trillions of dollars
from some of the biggest banks in the
industry
so you are seeing a lot of pledges both
from uh banks but also you know from
from countries right you're seeing the
the net
zero pledges pile up tim and i think it
is
uh an understanding that we are in one
of the
largest transitions of our lifetimes
and the existential nature of this
is important but the technology and the
policy tailwinds
are essential right that the knowledge
of this was there before
but as the regulators are looking for
more disclosure from a climate risk
perspective
and policy makers are understanding that
tax incentives are essential for
getting various industries moving at the
scale in which we need and the pace
which we need
we're actually getting that flywheel
moving so jackie where do you where do
you see this going in the next uh
year or so so i think we're going to see
uh a couple of different things we're
going to see
more policy and ideally more um
collective or consistent policy around
the world clearly
europeans were ahead of us um the blind
administration
is moving forward and you're seeing
action and signaling
from you know all different departments
um
and also legislative action as well as
policy actions so a lot of movement and
and tailwind there i also think you're
seeing corporates
uh be much more transparent about this
this
age of radical transparency and
specifically stakeholder capitalism
this idea that companies that are
delivering for their employees that are
delivering
for their customers and for the
communities in which they operate
those are the firms that over the long
term are going to deliver for their
shareholders
and so companies are disclosing to
things like the stakeholder capitalism
metrics
uh like the task force on climate
related
risk disclosure so all of those
different pieces
will enable investors to more
holistically
evaluate the opportunities in this space
all right we're going to leave it there
jackie vanderbrog
bank of america's head of sustainable
and impact investing
for its chief investment office thanks
so much for your time and for your
insight this morning
coming up we're talking to obama's
former faith advisor about how
he's helping business leaders engage
with the cultural conversation around
race and meaningful conversations around
race
authentically we'll be back in two
minutes this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim steinovich and i'm jennifer
zabasancha in new york so within
minutes of the reading of the jury's
guilty verdict in the derek chauvin
murder trial responses flooded in many
of them
welcoming the news and many more calling
for even more change so
former president obama wrote on twitter
today a jury did the right thing
but true justice requires much more
nba player lebron james tweeted one word
accountability canadian prime minister
justin trudeau said on twitter in part
make no mistake systemic racism and
anti-black racism
still exist and they exist in canada too
our next guest shared his reaction on
twitter too
writing in part so much more work to do
but so grateful for this moment of
justice so joshua dubois is the ceo of
gage.ai
which advises executives at companies
including pinterest snapchat
and sephora on how to talk about race
and cancel proof
their campaigns and dei initiatives he
was also
the former faith advisor to president
obama joshua is joining us now
from maryland joshua thank you so much
for being here so first of all
we want to get your reaction to the
three guilty verdicts yesterday how did
it feel watching
for you it was a sigh of relief that
i had at that moment um it was a moment
of accountability and another step
towards justice this of course is not
perfect justice because
george floyd is not with us but we've
been on a long journey as a country and
this is another step
um towards greater equality and justice
joshua you you advise companies as jen
mentioned
including printer snap and and more i
want to talk a little bit about the
conversations that should be happening
uh inside office buildings right now
over
zoom as people remain virtually
what is the what is the the the right
way to talk about this
uh moving forward yeah it's a great
question you know the first thing is to
actually not talk it's to listen right
to listen to employees and other
internal stakeholders
listen to outside experts and and hear
from them about what
how they're processing this what they're
going through and what they think you
should do the second thing is to
really communicate solidarity that
you're standing with
impacted communities the third thing is
to do what you do best right you don't
necessarily have to get out of your lane
for example
one of our subscribers sephora is a
retailer and so they focus on the
problem
of racial bias in retail settings
another subscriber procter gamble
is one of the biggest advertisers in the
world and so they think about how they
can have
a more diverse and inclusive advertising
approach and how their um
the messages and the images that they
are communicating in their advertising
so focus on that
that you do best and think about how you
can have an impact there and joshua you
mentioned a few of the companies that
you're working with
um and that you worked with last summer
um has your work sort of changed
since we saw the killing of george floyd
last year i mean how has it evolved in
the past year
um and how do you expect it to evolve
especially now that we have these guilty
verdicts
sure well it's certainly grown and
increases we get a lot of incoming
requests so gauge.ai is a software
platform that
connects decision makers in brands with
leaders in culture
every day these are the types of leaders
in culture that used to just weigh in
after the fact we're bringing them into
the process confidentially early on to
weigh in on ad campaigns and
you know and messaging strategic
questions and more we're basically
closing the gap between cultural leaders
and decision makers and major brands and
so one of the things that we're seeing
is a lot of folks are saying
you know we have a strategic plan around
our products around our employees and
our hr strategy but we don't have plans
around
this changing culture and so we're
helping them develop those plans
and implement these new tools josh well
you heard jen read from
former president obama's tweet that he
sent in in the wake of this
decision from the jury are you still in
touch with
with the president do you still advise
him so yeah we are honored to stay close
to the
both the former president and the obama
foundation and support wherever we can
yeah have you talked to him about this
not about this subject no yeah
i'm wondering what you would uh you know
give me an idea of what you have been
been speaking with him about and
and give us an idea of what he's been
thinking about since he has left office
and and we've seen the conversation
about race change so much
well you know what i've seen the former
president and the former first lady
focus on is long-term systemic change so
for example with their my brother's
keeper initiative
thinking about how they can pour into
men and boys of color in the long run
setting up mentoring programs and
and other initiatives to really
strengthen those communities or the
first lady's efforts with women and
girls you know this is a
again a long journey we've been on as a
country we've
you know from slavery to jim crow to the
civil rights era and now we've had
basically
350 years of really tough stuff in just
50 or 60 years where we're just
beginning
um to figure some of these pieces out
and so what what i've always appreciated
about the former president and and first
lady is that they're focused on the long
run and that's where their interventions
have been
and joshua i mean we're still seeing
corporations that are
are sometimes making these mistakes
right and making these embarrassing gaps
as you've noted uh what are three things
that you would advise them
uh if you were talking to them today
well first thing is
assess the tools that they're using to
evaluate you know their messaging
and and their ad campaigns and making
sure that those tools are inclusive
the second thing is listen to their
diverse employees right they're folks
that are
within these organizations that already
know sort of the best approach to these
issues and make sure those people
are empowered and the third is i
mentioned it before but do what you do
well you can stay in your lane and have
a massive impact whether that
is as a retailer as an advertiser
whatever the case may be
in in real estate you can bring greater
equity and equality in the space that
you're in
but focus on how you can have that
impact in your space hey joshua i wonder
how you think about progress in the
context of your own business because if
i think about gage.ai uh it
would be an ultimate sign of success
right if your company no longer really
needs to exist
because those gaps between the way that
the boardroom is thinking
and the the way that uh the conversation
is happening outside of the company
like that would no longer exist right
well the interesting thing is that you
know there's always
going to be brilliant leaders in culture
who who want to make sure that they are
shaping decisions within these board
rooms and so
we are basically a platform that serves
as that connecting point
it's interesting it's actually diverse
leaders in these organizations that are
reaching out to us most saying we need
better tools
to bring to others in our organization
so i think we will be able to grow
as these companies grow more sensitive
and nuance to these issues
who else are you working with joshua i
mean we mentioned a few of the companies
but uh
where else will you be uh lending your
efforts
yeah so you know as we talked about
sephora and racial bias and retail and
procter and gamble and the work that
they're doing in advertisement
we love working for example with
snapchat as they develop
more inclusive ar tools and we're
helping them shape those tools in
partnership with
uh with diverse leaders we're working
with pinterest with the cw network a
cable network thinking about how they
are portraying diverse communities on
screen and so
the work is really growing right now and
we're honored to advise these leaders
and most importantly connect them using
software
uh with stakeholders and communities
joshua dubois ceo of gage.ai joshua
thanks so much for taking the time
really appreciate you joining us on
quick take today well coming up
we're looking at how the pandemic
reinvented the at-home fitness
industry also what's going to happen to
peloton when in-person studios and
boutique fitness classes start
all up again we're back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well the at-home
smart fitness boom flourish during the
pandemic well boutique studios shuttered
so what happens when the pandemic passes
quick take chief correspondent
jason kelly explores peloton's rise and
more in his latest episode of business
of sport out tomorrow
here's a sneak peek
we saw the sales spike you know almost
right away
not just that people were finding out
about peloton and interested in
the bike or the tread but that they had
no choice
peloton went from a kickstarter project
to a company worth more than
30 billion dollars in just a few years
but as the world starts to slowly return
to normal what happens next for at home
fitness
there's an interesting survey that we
saw that 59 percent of americans
said they're not going back to the gym
after covet if you don't think that
represents a big opportunity for peloton
to continue
selling bikes and treads so you're crazy
what's up peloton
yes welcome to my house i am coming to
you live from my parents home
when those classes live from home came
out it was
a super special moment for for
internally
at the folks at peloton we really wanted
to be there for them with not just
content because you could have taken a
class from
last year but something authentic took
place when we didn't
live from home because it's hey i'm here
peloton stock which opened in 2019 to a
tepid response
grew into one of the best performing
stocks in the world
even amid a massive bull market and
let's be honest the peloton
it's expensive yes you can finance it
but this is a bike that costs on average
about twenty five hundred dollars just
to get it then you've got a monthly fee
on top of that
every other person you talk to will say
what happens to pelton after cover
people think that it's dark dark clouds
on the horizon for peloton
that pessimism and disbelief in us fuels
you know fuels our fire and there's
still so many naysayers that
we're excited to prove wrong
well jason kelly is here with us now
jason thanks so much for
joining us look you literally wrote the
book on connected fitness right
sweat equity it came out a few years ago
you use a peloton
as you talk about in this and looking
back over the last year i mean it kind
of seems inevitable that peloton would
have this moment
but many dismiss this company from its
earliest days
as something that wouldn't actually
catch on take us through what you've
learned
well absolutely tim i mean i was one of
those people when i wrote that book back
in 2016
peloton was really just coming on the
scene in many ways i knew about it
i knew that people were liking it to
some extent but it wasn't catching on
really with investors
and i like many others thought you know
what that's not where fitness is going
we're in an era where people want to be
with other people in these cool boutique
studios and that was really
my focus that was true for a time but
even
before the pandemic peloton caught onto
something it figured out how to marry
technology
and community and obviously as we just
heard
the pandemic it just went gangbusters
and jason i mean john
seems so confident that uh you know
peloton is going to continue
uh its popularity with consumers i mean
where does that come from
i think it comes from the the depth and
the devotion of the communi community
so far i mean these are people who feel
very connected
pun intended to this brand there are
you know facebook groups that have built
up around this massive social media
presence they've also expanded pretty
dramatically
away from the bike you know into the
treadmill into
you know all sorts of other modalities
as they say the
app is very very popular you know given
you can do pilates and yoga
and boot camp type workouts so they see
as as you heard john say just a huge
amount of upside going forward
it seems like jason a real big part of
ingredient in the secret sauce
is the celebrity instructors these
instructors that they have take us into
who they are
how they're able to make the transition
during the pandemic to go from studio
in home and how they're compensated
because
they're making some serious money they
are making some serious money and and
that's because they
are as you say they're celebrities in
many ways and i do think
you know one of the brilliant things
that peloton was able to do and john
talks about this in depth in the piece
is they set these folks up at home and
by they
the instructors themselves had to set
themselves up and i mean you guys all
remember
we couldn't leave our houses we
certainly couldn't have anyone into our
house and so
you had these technicians who were you
know on facetime being like all right
put the camera here put the camera there
and there they were doing classes from
home and
the reason that they are so beloved in
many ways is there's a real intimacy
that they create and that only was
heightened i think during the pandemic
and jason i'll say it because i have
used it on before and i
love these instructors so much and
really like you mentioned i mean there's
a connection
that they make with the audience there's
the hashtags that you mentioned
um does that mean going forward i mean
is there anybody that can compete with
peloton at this point i mean you
mentioned all of the other
offerings that they have they have bar
they have pilates they have outdoor
running i mean can
anyone compete with where peloton has
gone at this point well they're
certainly trying to and you know one of
the interesting
newer but actually not so new entrants
in all of this but you know gaining
a little bit of attention is beachbody
you probably remember them from
insanity and p90x they are going public
via spac
they have an investment from kevin mayer
who ran a big chunk of disney and then
went on to run tick-tock thomas stags
who also worked at disney
their spac is what's taking a beachbody
public and interestingly
mixed fitness i believe tim spoke with
the president of mix herbie countless
not too long ago
mix is part of that uh new beachbody so
they've got a lot of competition coming
and some of the competition is candidly
going to be
people going back to the boutique
studios well so to so to that point
jason
and i love the way that your piece
starts out because it like really took
me back on memory lane thinking about
workout videos like straight up vhs
videos at home fitness
it's nothing new right this didn't start
during the pandemic
but the road to peloton is is littered
with the carcasses of companies that
really were had a hot moment but aren't
really doing well
anymore and you speak to some of these
people um how do you prevent or how does
john foley prevent
peloton from being a pandemic fad i
think you
they have to continually innovate they
have to continually come up with
the content i mean this is ultimately a
content company in
in many ways yes it's a technology
company yes it's a fitness company
but the content is what wins the day
going back to what we were talking about
with the instructors so
it's got to be fresh it's got to be
engaging it's got to be engaging in a
way that you feel like not only you have
a connection with the instructors
but this broader community around them
and
that is going to be critical sort of
keeping
that group together going forward it'll
be so interesting to watch and
we will be watching it jason we know you
will be too quick take chief
correspondent jason kelly
thanks so much for your time and for
your reporting of course and you can
check out the next episode of business
of sports tomorrow morning on quick
takes youtube page
up next the white house is doubling down
on obama era emission standards we'll be
back in two minutes this is quick take
charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenenbeck and i'm jennifer
zabasanja in new york let's look at some
developing stories we are tracking this
morning
white house officials have told
supporters they will pledge
to reduce u.s greenhouse gas emissions
by at least
half by the end of the decade that's an
almost doubling
of the nation's earlier commitment the
goals being discussed
ahead of this week's international
climate summit
prescription eyewear seller warby parker
is considering an
ipo possibly this year bloomberg has
learned
the company is in talks with advisors
warby parker raised 120 million in its
most recent funding round
in 2020 that gave it a valuation of 3
billion
dollars and you can learn more about
these stories and stay up to date on the
day's news
at bloomberg.com you have warby parker's
right john i do i have them on right now
and i was just
yeah i was just talking to them actually
yesterday it has been i mean look it's
been a long time coming for this company
it's been a venture back company for for
years and years they went with that
tom's model the one for one we recently
had jordan holman on the show who wrote
an article about toms
how they're moving away from that
one-to-one model i really
look forward to seeing the s-1 the
prospectus from warby parker and and
seeing how they're thinking about
charitable giving moving forward and
also
they've moved into other parts of the
business when it comes to eyewear like
contact lenses for example yeah and
they're totally expensive i mean they're
opening more brick and mortar stores and
so it's just going to be really
interesting to see
where this company continues to go and
we of course will continue to bring the
latest when we get it well that's going
to do it for quick take this hour
but there is much more quick take coming
up in just a minute i'm tim steinovich
and i'm jennifer zabasaja you can check
out the latest stories at bloomberg.com
or at quicktake on social media
thanks for watching
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to bloomberg
quick take where we bring you today's
top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
coming up today world leaders and
activists are calling derek chovin's
guilty verdict a turning point
in the fight for justice under minnesota
law he
he faces up to four decades in prison
but this is only one case
and while the verdict could change how
police use excessive force
it also might relieve pressure from
congress to act on police reform we'll
talk with the aclu senior staff
attorney of its criminal law reform
project and former president obama's
spiritual advisor
then all eyes are on india which is
turning into the new epicenter of the
covid crisis
investors are calculating india's role
in the global economic recovery
and we're learning it's more crucial
than previously anticipated
and is netflix already past its peak as
the world is beginning to reopen from
covet 19 lockdowns
fewer people are signing up for the
service and that's worrying
investors we'll discuss what it means
for the future of the streaming service
and other work from home stocks
that were embraced early on in the
pandemic i'm tim stenovich and i'm
jennifer zabasanja and this is quick
take charge
let's get going
well it was a verdict heard around the
world former minneapolis police officer
derek chauvin
was found guilty of killing george floyd
when he knelt on floyd's neck for nine
minutes and 29 seconds
a videotaped death that ignited a summer
of protest
and marked the beginning of the greatest
racial reckoning in the u.s
since the 60s and now president biden is
calling on congress to honor george
floyd's passing
honor george floyd by passing lasting
law enforcement reform
house democrats have passed legislation
that imposes restrictions on federal
authorities but in the senate the bill
doesn't have a clear path to a
to a filibuster-proof 60-vote majority
joining us now is senior staff attorney
at the
aclu some trevetti and bloomberg news's
white house reporter mario parker both
of them are in washington d.c for us
so samia we wanted to start with you
first of all let's get your reaction to
three guilty verdicts uh yesterday what
did you think
thanks for having me i think um relief
is probably the word that a lot of
people are feeling here uh
i think a lot of folks are also calling
it justice which i would stop
short of uh it's a it's a small measure
of accountability i hope it brings
healing to the family and the community
but
for true justice we need to make sure
that the george floyds of the world
never get killed in the first place so
they can go home to their families like
everybody else
so we have a long way to go hey mario to
somal's point about true justice making
sure that this doesn't happen in the
future
take us into what's happening in in
washington d.c
about changes that we could potentially
see
if democrats are able to pull this off
no absolutely we saw uh president biden
come out with remarks uh yesterday
evening
and the bulk of those remarks were uh
his
using the bully pool pit to push uh
the george floyd policing act he was
really throwing the weight of the white
house behind it
saying that this is the moment for that
type of legislation to pass
to get past some of the gridlock as well
you see excuse me you see some of the
the normal
you know chokeholds and strangleholds in
in dc right now in terms of legislation
but you also see some type of glimmers
some some glimmers of hope
in the form of bipartisanship uh tim
scott was out
a republican with a statement as well as
amy klobuchar
so there are some glimmers of hope that
something can be reached
so so what could be uh mario what what
could be like a federal
law though you know so because we do do
have some of these changes happening
throughout the country or at least being
proposed in different states and as you
mentioned in washington dc
what could the federal government do in
order to put restrictions in place
to hopefully i i can't say never happen
again because we've already seen this
happen
since last year but but to prevent
this from from continuing yeah what
we're seeing also of course
is just the limitations of the executive
branch
joe biden over the past year as
candidate then candidate biden
has called for police reform of course
the george floyd protests
uh occurred during the backdrop of the
presidential election
uh he's come out uh since assuming
office
with executive orders but of course
those only go so far
the only thing that could really have
lasting change and the administration is
admitting as much
is if some type of congressional
legislation is passed
again we've got a 50-50 deadlock in in
dc
uh as you all mentioned at the top of
the the show
uh george floyd act uh passed in the
house
it's kind of stalled in the senate the
senate has issues with the filibuster et
cetera
but the the white house is trying as
much as they can at least
from what we understand and from what
they're telling telling
us to uh really prod congress and
the hill to to move forward with
something and samil you tweeted that
this was just a verdict and justice is
yet to come and you also reiterated that
just now
um are the bills that you have seen out
there the george floyd justice and
policing act do they go far enough uh
and if not what more do you want to see
from legislators
yeah a lot more um i was really
disappointed by the reports
that uh this verdict is quote unquote
easing the pressure i mean talk about
not reading a room right millions of
people did not march
all summer last year to get one verdict
out of one courtroom in minnesota
they marched to get lasting systemic
eradication of police brutality and
systemic racism
so we are not nearly done the bills in
congress
now are are good we look forward to
working with the senate to get something
even better and namely
um we need to make sure that we are not
pumping money back
in to the broken systems of training and
technology
that have failed us so far instead we
need to get that money back into
communities
and extract police from a lot of the
low-level interactions that get us into
these dangerous situations in the
first place yeah so
the the the the guilty verdict on these
three charges is obviously a a huge part
of this but sentencing is still
coming in the future we don't know what
the sentencing will be
uh but i'm wondering how you think the
judge is thinking about sentencing and
also
how sentencing will send a message
yeah you know so i take a little
different view here um
sentencing will take a message we'll
send a message we know that the
prosecution has
asked for aggravating factors to be
tacked on
so that the ultimate sentence is
probably closer to
um the maximums allowed under minnesota
law um
i hope frankly in eight weeks when we're
talking about sentencing
the national conversation has moved so
far forward into prevention
and reinvesting in communities that it's
a non-story but i don't doubt that the
prosecution will try to send a message
to other police officers not just the
other ones in george floyd's own case
but
around the country and mario we want to
bring you back in here
um you mentioned senator tim scott and
there's a number of other lawmakers who
are also trying to push for reform
what is happening though behind the
scenes to get more republicans on board
because tim scott is going to need
republicans in order to get this passed
it's a tough slog senator scott has been
working on this since
last summer he actually was able to get
support from
then president trump but they couldn't
really rally the party around
the large-scale changes that that
advocates say are needed for
policing reform uh so it's gonna be a
really tough slog
uh it's a politically uh you know
divisive
issue it's a politically fraught issue
even within the republican caucus
so it's to be tough for him to rally or
get to really rally around and get
support
uh to to cross bipartisan lines and get
something across the the finish line
here
hey somal very briefly um
if we think a year from now what is the
the legacy
of of this verdict going to be
i think um it allowed us the breathing
room to have the larger conversations
that i'm talking about we can all
imagine what would have happened
if this system let down black and brown
communities yet again
um and so it's almost the absence
of a catastrophe that we can celebrate
here
and hopefully over the next year like i
said we'll be
well down the road to having a
conversation about how to make sure that
this never happens again
aclu's senior staff attorney somal
trivedi and
bloomberg's mario parker a big thank you
to both of you for your time really
appreciate you joining us
on this well let's talk covid
it's time now for quick take by the
numbers it's where we give you the
numbers that tell the story
this morning's number is 2000. the world
health organization said that
chronovirus cases are rising in all
regions except europe with india
driving a surge in asia india reported a
record of more than 2 000 deaths on
wednesday
while cases rose by nearly 300 000.
india's health system is being overrun
it's not just a humanitarian disaster
but it also poses real risks to the
global economy
and the recovery india has nearly 18 of
the planet's population and the fifth
largest economy
it's not just the high risk of further
dangerous virus mutations in such an
uncontrolled outbreak
the country accounts for more than 12
percent of the world's labor force
that's according to world bank data
as bloomberg macro strategist mark
cudmore has written the disruption to
work and supply chains could be yet
another spur for global inflation
the rise in global cases has upset
financial markets solid earnings from
u.s companies have been overshadowed
by the threat of new lockdowns sapping
optimism that growth is set to roar back
from pandemic induced recessions and for
more on the latest we're joined by the
senior scholar with the
hopkins center for health security dr
amesh adalja in pittsburgh
dr adalja thanks so much for being here
so the u.s
is set to meet president biden's latest
vaccine goal of administering
200 million coronavirus shots in his
first 100
days in office with more than 50 percent
of adults at least partially
vaccinated and biden is expected to
outline his plans later today to ramp up
vaccination
efforts um what are you expecting to
hear what are you going to be looking
out for
what i expect to hear is how we're going
to turn covet vaccination into something
that's more routine
something that's easily accessible
that's more like a flu vaccine in terms
of the
logistics to sign up for one than it has
been in the past
i also want to hear about how we're
going to get those vaccine hesitant
people to be persuaded that this is
something that they should do that this
is something that will improve their
individual lives because
increasingly we're becoming less supply
constrained and more demand constrained
if you look yesterday
less than 2 million doses were given on
on tuesday so this is something we have
to worry about that are we kind of
hitting a peak
in terms of the people who want to get
vaccinated or all getting vaccinated and
we're left with a group that's
not willing to get vaccinated and that's
going to be an obstacle if we're going
to get
more control of these community cases
and have less disruption
of from the from the virus in our
business places in our in our schools
wherever it may be
and i really think that's going to be
the challenge going forward you know dr
adulta
it seems to me that one way to do this
is
is messaging and messaging the clear
benefits
of the vaccine it's something that
struck me yesterday with your appearance
on bloomberg tv and bloomberg radio
i i heard it throughout the day
yesterday the way that you talked about
how life changes after getting the
vaccine
i got to tell you it seems like you are
in the minority of
physicians out there right now talking
about
how much life can change just after
getting that single shot
who you can spend time with where you
can go wearing a mask outside versus not
wearing a mask outside
uh what do you think can what is the
right message to tell people who get the
vaccine
and why aren't we hearing more health
professionals say that
i hope that mine is the right message
because i've been somebody that is ahead
of the public health guidance in terms
of
what i think people can do safely once
they've been fully vaccinated and i tell
my friends i tell my patients
that they can go back to as much of
their original life as possible because
these vaccines are
highly effective not only at preventing
symptomatic disease but also decreasing
spread you don't really have to worry
about you yourself being
a spread a spreader of this virus and i
think what you see is many public health
officials
being very cautious they kind of want to
take baby steps they don't want to give
away too much because they think things
might get out of control again
and that people that are not vaccinated
might take the wrong message
but i think if you're not telling people
what the vaccine is going to do to their
individual life they're not going to
want to get it if you tell them every
nothing changes once you get the vaccine
and you advertise that fact
who's going to want to get a vaccine
because this is something that needs to
be seen as
something that's going to going to
better your individual life it's going
to allow you to pursue your values
allow you to be able to do things
without the worry of coping 19.
it does seem like officials are being
overly cautious though i mean i think
back to what dr fauci said a couple
weeks ago that even after getting the
vaccine he's not going to eat inside at
a restaurant do you think that's the
right move i mean are you going to eat
inside a restaurant
you've already gotten the vaccine i've
i've been eating in restaurants even
before i got the vaccine because i think
it can be done safely if you take
calculated risks
but yes once i was fully vaccinated i
went back to as much of my
normal life as as i could i think that
we've gotta
use that as the kind of uh at the at the
pot at the end of the rainbow that
you're going to get to some place where
life looks normal because that's why
people would want to get the vaccine
they're doing it to get their lives back
and i
i don't know why they don't say more of
this i think that they've undersold the
vaccine and then they're surprised that
there's vaccine hesitancy
they've created this pause with the
johnson johnson vaccine which is going
to add to vaccine hesitancy
and if we don't talk to people about how
this vaccine
is a piece of technology that's going to
make their lives better just like an
iphone makes your life better it's a
piece of technology they're not going to
want to get it
they're and we're not going to get that
group of vaccine hesitant people to move
or to budge and that means we're still
going to have tens of thousands of cases
occurring every day
and that we're going to be worried about
new variants and all the rest of it so
we have to really tell people that this
is
this is something they should do for
their own life that this is something
that's going to
to to change what they can do and i
think that we want the guidance to be
proactive right now the cdc guidance is
lagging
people were already meeting with other
vaccinated people people were already
traveling before the cdc guide and said
okay yes that's safe to do
that makes that guidance less relevant
the cdc needs to be ahead of it
talking about what people what people
will be doing
sooner talking about mass gatherings
talking about
vaccinated only sections in in sporting
and sporting
arenas all of that needs to be out there
so people can see this vaccine
as something they want to get like i
said the demand is
is the demand is going to start falling
away as we get into the general
population because it's not the
high-risk individuals it's not the
healthcare workers who are
eager to sign up that we're dealing with
now so so it's going to be a challenge
and i think we have to speak honestly
and
and not overly cautious talk about what
we don't know talk about where the
limitations are
but talk about what we do know and talk
about how to make calculated risks once
you're
vaccinated and we've been doing too much
abstinence only throughout this entire
pandemic
and we need to borrow from harm
reduction which we use in hiv and
sexually transmitted infections and with
injection drug use we need to take that
paradigm and it's been sorely missing
the entire pandemic and i think it's
created this breach between public
health and the general public
all right senior scholar with the
hopkins center for health security dr
amae shadal joe we always love having
you thanks so much for your time
and we should note the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health is
supported by
michael r bloomberg founder of bloomberg
lp and bloomberg philanthropies
now we don't want to bury the lead on
the rest of the morning's top news so
here are some stories we don't want you
to miss
columbus police shot and killed a
teenage girl who swung at two other
people
with a knife on tuesday according to
body cam footage from
the officer it happened minutes
reportedly before the george floyd
verdict the decision to swiftly release
the video
was a departure from protocol as the
force faces immense scrutiny from the
public
following a series of recent
high-profile police killings that have
led
to clashes columbus mayor andrew ginther
mourned the loss of the young victim
but defended the officer's use of deadly
force
and remember that rebel soccer league in
europe well it's fallen apart just days
after its launch the chairman of italy's
juventus club
says the project will no longer go ahead
the collapse was inevitable after all
six
english teams involved pulled out of the
so-called super league
the idea as you may remember was blasted
by fans politicians
and soccer authorities and a ransomware
attack
may have stolen blueprints of apple's
latest
products during its announcement
yesterday one of apple's primary
suppliers quanta
was hit with a ransomware attack from a
russian operator
the ransom was 50 million dollars quanta
acknowledged and attacked without
explaining if or
how much of its data was actually stolen
you can always learn more about these
stories and of course stay up to date on
the day's news at bloomberg.com
well coming up we are talking streaming
how did netflix miss its own subscriber
growth by
millions and should the company be
concerned investors certainly are
we're back in two minutes with the
details this is quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in
new york well let's talk streaming to
netflix reeling
this morning from the brutal reality
that an end of the pandemic
is bad for business netflix revealed
user growth for the first quarter
and it missed its own forecast by
millions of subscribers
the streaming service added 3.98 million
subscribers in the first quarter
uh sounds like a lot but analysts
expected an average of 6.29 million
and its own forecast also was 6 million
netflix says the current quarter will be
more challenging which could be the case
for other work from home businesses
we've been relying on during the
pandemic on the phone to discuss is
bloomberg intelligence senior media
analyst
gita ragnagathen who has been unpacking
netflix's earnings
and wrote it's important not to confuse
near-term noise in user gains
with netflix's longer-term thesis which
we believe remains stronger than
ever gita thanks so much for taking the
time uh explain what you mean here
because it really sounds similar
to the point that netflix executives
were making last night
in that earnings live stream it's
something they've talked about for years
right there can be noise with these
subscriber figures but
in the long run netflix is going to win
out
yeah um absolutely tim and uh saying
good morning tim and jennifer and thank
you so much for having me so this was
really the core i mean we've been
hearing about
you know this blowout in 2020 what's
going to happen in 2021
but this was really the quarter when
that pull forward of demand
hit hard uh but i think you know again
it it's
as you just mentioned i think it's
really important to kind of distinguish
between
you know the short-term transitory
issues that we're going to see with
the subscriber outlook and the long-term
growth potential
and you typically look at netflix in any
given year before the pandemic hit and
they've added about
28 to 30 million subscribers on average
of course last year was you know a
one-off they added about 40 million
but then you look at the long-term
growth potential we looked at the
long-term growth
trajectory and i think it remains pretty
much intact of course we are going to
have to deal with another
you know probably three to six months of
you know a little bit of ups and downs
and a little bit of noise when it comes
to the subscriber edition
but gita i mean there are still a number
of other streaming platforms out there
right so
what what does netflix need to do to
continue to keep customers
on the platform what is that long-term
strategy that you're talking about
oh absolutely so competition is is not
something that's new to netflix
what they really have to do is come out
with more and more
original content and they have
recognized this i mean originals and
exclusivity is what is going to
you know win the streaming wars for
netflix they know this
they have gone hard after you know
original content
and not just buying originals from other
studios but kind of
making their own originals think of
shows like stranger things think of
shows like you know the witcher or
bridgeton these are all shows that they
own they own the ip and they can you
know
they have plenty of flexibility they can
do whatever they want to do with the
show
and they know that and and um you know
they were spending about 15 billion
dollars uh in terms of programming costs
before the pandemic hit but this year
again that's ramping up
pretty significantly they did commit to
spending about 17 billion
or so and i think going out the next few
years we're going to see them spend
easily about
20 billion on content just to kind of
you know make
those high-profile shows make those
high-profile movies
and all your new subscribers that is a
lot of money to spend on content gita
i'm wondering how the coronavirus
pandemic has derailed
production worldwide because the thing
about netflix is it's so
easy to sign up for but it's just as
easy to quit if you don't have anything
to watch
yes and i mean that is kind of the big
uh the question mark for all of these
streaming services right i mean
yes easy to sign up but also easy to
kind of churn out of
it it is obviously a huge concern but i
think if you just kind of compare
netflix uh both in terms of quality and
quantity of content i think they have
established themselves as the go-to
service
and then you kind of look at them and
their price points versus their
competitors
yes they're pricey but i think again the
value proposition is compelling
so again just to go back to your point
on on originals and on productions
covet 19 has obviously derailed
productions there was a there was you
know these huge shutdowns and that's
kind of taken a toll on this first
half content slate which is why which is
partly responsible for
uh you know both the uh lower
subscribers and one
in one queue as well as the weak
guidance for 2q but i think
ironically what's going to happen is i
think netflix is also going to kind of
be coming
become this reopening play because as
those covet productions ease you're
going to see
so much more content kind of come on
board
in the second half uh you know as we
have those reopenings and
i think that is really going to drive a
huge increase in subscriber gain so they
already talked about a lot of their big
heavy hitting titles coming on online
you know you have the witcher you have
kobrakai you have
money heist these are all titles that
attract a lot of subscribers i think
they should be in pretty good shape
in the latter part of the year oh man
even more content on netflix just what
we need right uh
bloomberg intelligence senior media
analyst gita ragnaronthen
thank you so much for your time and for
your insight this morning up next
why more people are getting into clean
energy investments and how that changes
the timeline
for earth's shifts from fossil fuels to
renewables we'll be back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the difference
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey welcome back to take charge i'm
jennifer zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec
in
new york well joe biden has touted the
potential for the solar and wind
industries to create the types of jobs
that the u.s economy has been losing for
decades
and investors see there are good
opportunities in sustainable innovations
bank of america says clean energy
investments grew 47
from 2019 to 2020 and continues to grow
with some 50
of advisors putting money toward five or
more sustainable assets for clients
analysts are also bullish with ubs
predicting that electric vehicles will
be 100
of the automobile market by the year
2040.
here to discuss is jackie vanderbrugg
bank of america's head of sustainable
and impact investing for its chief
investment office
who's buying into green stocks and which
industries are getting the most play
jackie what are you seeing
so we do see this as a broad spectrum
tim like you say there's a lot of
tailwinds but historically it's helpful
to say
sustainable investors initially were
looking at either
getting out of certain industries
avoiding
or just those specific uh pure play
clean energy stocks and now we see a
much broader
spectrum of opportunities they really do
run the gamut from
green bonds as you noted or investments
in companies that are improving their
environmental footprint
green munis investments in cities and
municipalities that have
that focus around infrastructure
on the equity side companies that are
outperforming their peers
from an environmental standpoint but
also those that are improvers right
those that are
seeking to make the investments that are
going to allow them to lead
and have opportunities for new revenue
streams in the future
and then on the private side a lot of
work
again in renewables as you said but also
venture
in carbon capture capture and storage so
i think it's important to get the fact
that this is a full
spectrum across all asset classes and
across
uh the the risk spectrum as well jackie
how how crucial is it to
uh investing in in uh renewables at this
point in time
well we are seeing this energy
transition
as as you noted and the opportunity that
investors have i think they've seen in a
way that we maybe all
knew initially um but we felt through
the covet
crisis so we saw kovit as this
unexpected
accelerant where individuals and
institutions now
saw the vulnerability that we all have
whether it's that pandemics don't
stop at borders whether it's that
extreme weather is
increasing and affecting all of us we're
we have this
collective knowledge the other side is
that we are clearly
seeing that sustainable investments
broadly are out
uh are not underperforming which was the
myth i will say
the historically sustainable investments
um including these investments in
renewables
were seen as riskier or a way to
ethically lose money
and what we've done is we've really
disproved that so
we we've seen over the past years that
sustainable investments
are performing um at a risk-adjusted
basis better
than their peers in their asset classes
and that really has
made investors uh wake up and be very
excited
jackie i want to talk a little bit about
incentives specifically tax incentives
because there are a lot of reasons to
invest in sustainables but the tax
benefits are are really substantial
i'm i'm wondering if you can talk a
little bit about how
those tax benefits have played a role if
any
in the recent pledges that number in the
trillions of dollars
from some of the biggest banks in the
industry
so you are seeing a lot of pledges both
from
uh banks but also you know from from
countries right
you're seeing the the net zero pledges
pile up tim and i think it is uh an
understanding that we are in one of the
largest transitions um of our lifetimes
and the existential nature of this
is important but the technology and the
policy tailwinds
are essential right that the knowledge
of this was there before
but as the regulators are looking for
more disclosure from a climate risk
perspective
and the policy makers are understanding
that
tax incentives are essential for
getting various industries moving at the
scale in which we need and the pace
which we need
we're actually getting that flywheel
moving so jackie where do you where do
you see this going in the next
uh year or so so i think we're going to
see
a couple of different things we're going
to see
more policy and ideally more
collective or consistent policy around
the world
clearly europeans were ahead of us
the bind administration is moving
forward and you're seeing
action and signaling from you know all
different
departments um and also legislative
action as well as
policy actions so a lot of movement and
and
tailwind there i also think you're
seeing corporates
uh be much more transparent about this
this
age of radical transparency and
specifically stakeholder capitalism
this idea that companies that are
delivering for their employees that are
delivering
for their customers and for the
communities in which they operate
those are the firms that over the long
term are going to deliver for their
shareholders
and so companies are disclosing to
things like the stakeholder capitalism
metrics
uh like the task force on uh climate
related
risk disclosure so all of those
different pieces will
enable investors to more holistically
evaluate the opportunities in this space
all right we're going to leave it there
jackie vanderbrog
bank of america's head of sustainable
and impact investing
for its chief investment office thanks
so much for your time and for your
insight this morning
coming up we're talking to obama's
former faith advisor about how he's
helping business leaders
engage with the cultural conversation
around race and
meaningful conversations around race
authentically we'll be back in two
minutes this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim steinovich and i'm jennifer
zabasanja in new york so within
minutes of the reading of the jury's
guilty verdict in the derek chovin
murder trial responses flooded in many
of them
welcoming the news and many more calling
for even more change so
former president obama wrote on twitter
today a jury did the right thing but
true justice requires much more nba
player lebron james tweeted one word
accountability canadian prime minister
justin trudeau said on twitter
in part make no mistake systemic racism
and anti-black racism
still exist and they exist in canada too
our next guest
shared his reaction on twitter too
writing in part so much more work
to do but so grateful for this moment of
justice so joshua dubois is the ceo of
gage.ai
which advises executives at companies
including pinterest snapchat
and sephora on how to talk about race
and cancel proof
their campaigns and dei initiatives he
was also
the former faith advisor to president
obama joshua is joining us now
from maryland joshua thank you so much
for being here so first of all
we want to get your reaction to the
three guilty verdicts yesterday how did
it feel watching
for you it was a sigh of relief that
i had at that moment it was a moment of
accountability
and another step towards justice this of
course is not perfect justice because
george floyd is not with us but we've
been on a long journey as a country and
this is another step
um towards greater equality and justice
joshua you you advise companies as jen
mentioned
including printer snap and and more i
want to talk a little bit about the
conversations that should be happening
uh inside office buildings right now
over
zoom as people remain virtually
what is the what is the the the right
way to talk about this
uh moving forward yeah it's a great
question you know the first thing is to
actually not talk it's to listen right
to listen to employees and other
internal stakeholders
listen to outside experts and and hear
from them about what how they're
processing this what they're going
through and what they think
you should do the second thing is to
really communicate solidarity that
you're standing with
impacted communities the third thing is
to do what you do best right you don't
necessarily have to get out of your lane
for example
one of our subscribers sephora is a
retailer and so they focus on the
problem
of racial bias in retail settings
another subscriber procter gamble
is one of the biggest advertisers in the
world and so they think about how they
can have
a more diverse and inclusive advertising
approach and how they're
the messages and the images that they
are communicating in their advertising
so focus on that that you do best
and think about how you can have an
impact there and joshua you mentioned a
few of the companies that you're working
with
um and that you worked with last summer
um has your work sort of changed
since we saw the killing of george floyd
last year i mean how has it evolved in
the past year
um and how do you expect it to evolve
especially now that we have these guilty
verdicts
sure well it's certainly grown and
increased as we get a lot of incoming
requests so gage.ai is a software
platform that
connects decision makers in brands with
leaders in culture
every day these are the types of leaders
in culture that used to just weigh in
after the fact we're bringing them
into the process confidentially early on
to weigh in on ad campaigns and
you know and messaging strategic
questions and more we're basically
closing the gap between cultural leaders
and decision makers in major brands and
so one of the things that we're seeing
is a lot of folks are saying
you know we have a strategic plan around
our products around our employees and
our hr strategy but we don't have plans
around
this changing culture and so we're
helping them develop those plans
and implement these new tools josh well
you heard jen read from
former president obama's tweet that he
sent in the in the wake of this uh
decision from the jury
are you still in touch with with the
president do you still advise him
so yeah we are honored to stay close to
the both the former president and the
obama foundation and support wherever we
can yeah
have you talked to him about this not
about this subject no yeah
i'm wondering what you would uh you know
give me an idea of what you have been
been speaking with him about and
and give us an idea of what he's been
thinking about since he has left office
and we've seen the conversation about
race change so much
well you know what i've seen the former
president and the former first lady
focus on is long-term systemic change so
for example with their my brother's
keeper initiative
thinking about how they can pour into
men and boys of color in the long run
setting up mentoring programs and
and other initiatives to really
strengthen those communities or the
first lady's efforts with women and
girls you know this is a
again a long journey we've been on as a
country we've
you know from slavery to jim crow to the
civil rights era and now we've had
basically
350 years of really tough stuff in just
50 or 60 years where we're just
beginning
to figure some of these pieces out and
so what i've always appreciated about
the former president and and first lady
is that they're focused on the long run
and that's where their interventions
have been
and joshua i mean we're still seeing
corporations that are
are sometimes making these mistakes
right and making these embarrassing gaps
as you've noted uh what are three things
that you would advise them
if you were talking to them today well
first thing is
assess the tools that they're using to
evaluate you know their messaging
and and their ad campaigns and making
sure that those tools are inclusive
the second thing is listen to their
diverse employees right they're folks
that are
within these organizations that already
know sort of the best approach to these
issues and make sure those people
are empowered and the third is i mention
it before but do what you do well you
can stay in your lane and have a massive
impact whether that
is as a retailer as an advertiser
whatever the case may be in in real
estate you can
bring greater equity and equality in the
space that you're in
but focus on how you can have that
impact in your space hey joshua i wonder
how you think about progress in the
context of your own business because if
i think about gage.ai it
would be an ultimate sign of success
right if your company no longer really
needs to exist
because those gaps between the way that
the boardroom is thinking
and the the way that the conversation is
happening outside of the company
like that would no longer exist right
well the interesting thing is that you
know there's always
going to be brilliant leaders in culture
who who want to make sure that they are
shaping decisions within these board
rooms and so
we are basically a platform that serves
as that connecting point
and it's interesting it's actually
diverse leaders in these organizations
that are reaching out to us most saying
we need better tools
to bring to others in our organization
so i think we will be able to grow
as these companies grow more sensitive
and nuance to these issues
who else are you working with joshua i
mean we mentioned a few of the companies
but uh
where else will you be uh lending your
efforts
yeah so you know as we talked about
sephora and racial bias and retail and
procter and gamble and the work that
they're doing in advertisement
we love working for example with
snapchat as they develop
more inclusive ar tools and we're
helping them shape those tools in
partnership with
uh with diverse leaders we're working
with pinterest with the cw network a
cable network thinking about how they
are portraying diverse communities on
screen and so
the work is really growing right now and
we're honored to advise these leaders
and most importantly connect them using
software
uh with stakeholders and communities
joshua dubois ceo of gage.ai joshua
thanks so much for taking the time
really appreciate you joining us on
quick take today well coming up
we're looking at how the pandemic
reinvented the at-home fitness
industry also what's going to happen to
peloton when in-person studios and
boutique fitness classes start all up
again we're back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well the at home a smart fitness
boom flourish during the pandemic
well boutique studios shuttered so what
happens when the pandemic passes
quick take chief correspondent jason
kelly explores peloton's rise
and more in his latest episode of
business of sport out tomorrow
here's a sneak peek
we saw the sail spike you know almost
right away
not just that people were finding out
about peloton and interested in
the bike or the tread but that they had
no choice
peloton went from a kickstarter project
to a company worth more than
30 billion dollars in just a few years
but as the world starts to slowly return
to normal what happens next for at home
fitness
there's an interesting survey that we
saw that 59 percent of americans
said they're not going back to the gym
after covet if you don't think that
represents a big opportunity for peloton
to continue
selling bikes and treads you're crazy
what's up peloton
yes welcome to my house i am coming to
you live from my parents home
i won those classes live from home came
out it was
a super special moment for for
internally
at the folks at peloton we really wanted
to be there for them with not just
content because you could have taken a
class from
last year but something authentic took
place
when we did live from home because it's
hey i'm here
peloton stock which opened in 2019 to a
tepid response
grew into one of the best performing
stocks in the world
even amid a massive bull market and
let's be honest the peloton
it's expensive yes you can finance it
but this is a bike that costs on average
about twenty five hundred dollars just
to get it then you've got a monthly fee
on top of that every other person you
talk to will say what happens to pelton
after covert people think that
it's dark dark clouds on the horizon for
peloton
that pessimism and disbelief in us fuels
you know fuels our fire and there's
still so many naysayers that
we're excited to prove wrong
[Music]
well jason kelly is here with us now
jason thanks so much for
joining us look you literally wrote the
book on connected fitness right
sweat equity it came out a few years ago
you use a peloton
as you talk about in this and looking
back over the last year i mean it kind
of seems inevitable that peloton would
have this moment
but many dismiss this company from its
earliest days
as something that wouldn't actually
catch on take us through what you've
learned
well absolutely tim i mean i was one of
those people when i wrote that book back
in 2016
peloton was really just coming on the
scene in many ways i knew about it
i knew that people were liking it to
some extent but it wasn't catching on
really with investors
and i like many others thought you know
what that's not where fitness is going
we're in an era where people want to be
with other people in these cool boutique
studios and that was really
my focus that was true for a time but
even
before the pandemic peloton caught onto
something it figured out how to marry
technology
and community and obviously as we just
heard the pandemic
it just went gangbusters and jason i
mean john
seems so confident that you know peloton
is going to continue
uh its popularity with consumers i mean
where does that come from
i think it comes from the the depth and
the devotion of the community community
so far
i mean these are people who feel very
connected
pun intended to this brand there are you
know facebook groups that have built up
around this
massive social media presence they've
also expanded pretty dramatically
away from the bike you know into the
treadmill into
you know all sorts of other modalities
as they say the app
is very very popular you know given you
can do pilates and yoga
and boot camp type workouts so they see
as you heard john say just a huge amount
of upside going forward
it seems like jason a real big part of
ingredient in the secret sauce
is the celebrity instructors these
instructors that they have take us into
who they are
how they're able to make the transition
during the pandemic to go from
studio in home and how they're
compensated because
they're making some serious money they
are making some serious money and and
that's because they
are as you say they're celebrities in
many ways and i do
think you know one of the brilliant
things that peloton was able to do and
john talks about this in depth in the
piece
is they set these folks up at home and
by they
the instructors themselves had to set
themselves up and i mean you guys all
remember
we couldn't leave our houses we
certainly couldn't have anyone into our
house and so
you had these technicians who were you
know on facetime being like all right
put the camera here put the camera there
and there they were doing classes from
home and
the reason that they are so beloved in
many ways is there's a real intimacy
uh that they create and that only was
heightened i think during the pandemic
and jason i'll say it because i
have used about on before and i love
these instructors so much and really
like you mentioned i mean there's a
connection
that they make with the audience there's
the hashtags that you mentioned
um does that mean going forward i mean
is there anybody that can compete with
peloton at this point i mean you
mentioned all of the other
offerings that they have they have bar
they have pilates they have outdoor
running i mean can anyone
compete with where peloton has gone at
this point well they're certainly trying
to and you know one of the interesting
newer but actually not so new entrants
in all of this but you know gaining
a little bit of attention is beachbody
you probably remember them from
insanity and p90x they are going public
via spac
they have an investment from kevin mayer
who ran a big chunk of disney and then
went on to run tick-tock thomas stags
who also worked at disney
their spac is what's taking a beachbody
public and interestingly
mixed fitness i believe tim spoke with
the president of mix herbert's not too
long ago
mix is part of that uh new beachbody so
they've got a lot of competition coming
and some of the competition is candidly
going to be
people going back to the boutique
studios well so to so to that point
jason
and i love the way that your piece
starts out because it like really took
me back on memory lane thinking about
workout videos like straight up vhs
videos at home fitness
it's nothing new right this didn't start
during the pandemic
but the road to peloton is is littered
with the carcasses of companies that
really were had a hot moment but aren't
really doing well
anymore and you speak to some of these
people um how do you prevent or how does
john foley prevent
peloton from being a pandemic fad i
think you they have to
continually innovate they have to
continually come up with
the content i mean this is ultimately a
content company in
in many ways yes it's a technology
company yes it's a fitness company
but the content is what wins the day
going back to what we were talking about
with the instructors so
it's got to be fresh it's got to be
engaging it's got to be engaging in a
way that you feel like not only you have
a connection with the instructors
but this broader community around them
and
that is going to be critical sort of
keeping
that group together going forward it'll
be so interesting to watch and
we will be watching it jason we know you
will be too quick chief correspondent
jason kelly
thanks so much for your time and for
your reporting of course and you can
check out the next episode of business
of sports tomorrow morning on quick
takes youtube page
up next the white house is doubling down
on obama era emission standards we'll be
back in two minutes this is quick take
charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenoveck and i'm jennifer zabasanja
in new york let's look at some
developing stories we are tracking this
morning
white house officials have told
supporters they will pledge
to reduce u.s greenhouse gas emissions
by at least
half by the end of the decade that's an
almost doubling
of the nation's earlier commitment the
goals being discussed
ahead of this week's international
climate summit
prescription eyewear seller warby parker
is considered